Stupid.
What's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Yeah.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
What's going on?
I don't know how much you heard of that before.
And he was just yelling at me.
She's over there pack and I'm like,
when are you going to be done fucking pack?
And so I can do the podcast.
Jesus Christ.
Did you bring it up?
Shoes near.
Okay.
Did you bring enough dresses?
Nia?
Oh,
the fuck was that?
Was this an American coin?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
what's going on?
Checking in on your week.
How's your week going?
Oh,
that's wonderful.
Isn't that wonderful?
My little vacation is winding down here.
Oh.
Must Deserved Russ.
Relaxation,
respite,
whatever the fuck people say.
Um,
I had a good time,
but I'm a workaholic.
So you know,
five days in I'm like,
all right dad,
does anybody got any lumber?
They needed shop.
I have difficulties fucking relaxing as everybody would say.
Yeah.
If you can walk around giving me Shit,
you're going to really affect you bringing the negative vibe.
So the other day,
Nia,
we go down,
we went down to the beach and I did what I usually don't do.
I got in to,
and why not an ocean?
It was a c.
This is the difference.
See,
I don't fuck with the ocean on any level is you people know when all of a sudden
now was the Mediterranean Sea am I go,
well,
you know,
you never hear about sharks in the sea from sea to shining sea.
There's no stairs.
Whatever song that is,
there's not one word about a shark,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
beautiful.
For spacious skies,
for amber waves stuff that's not the fucking star spangled banger.
That's a,
isn't that all beautiful?
What was it called?
Amber waves of grain for a purple mountains.
Bang
when it,
yeah.
Yeah,
but that's not in that song.
Yeah.
Hello.
Foyer space has guys for amber waves of grain per bar.
Mountain's majesty fruit
America.
Okay.
God shed his grace on thee after the genocide and some slave or re,
we build some skyscraper for the upper 1%
that's America.
The beautiful.
Oh,
okay.
I believe Katy Perry did a cover of it.
Didn't she Wes,
one of those girls with the big eyes,
nobody covers big guy.
Magoo national anthems.
Oh,
it's not a fucking national anthem.
It's a patriotic song.
Done.
But a bump,
bump,
bump.
Right.
Okay.
One.
So anyways,
uh,
so we go down to the minister rating,
see,
and I,
uh,
say,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm going in,
I'm going to,
I'm going to fucking swim.
And I swear to God,
my heart is never been fucking racing like that.
A body of water in my life.
I had my little swimming goggles,
right?
I got my head shaved.
So I look like I'm going to go fucking compete against,
uh,
the dude with the Bong and the 400 meters.
I have not watched one second of the Olympics and I gotta tell Ya,
I don't feel like I'm missing anything.
You know,
I love about the Olympics.
They get all this sports.
No one gives a fuck about out of the way.
Once every four years I already have.
They are somebody on skis with a rifle,
cross country ski diving.
And what do you into?
You Watch football,
you watch hockey?
Nah,
I'm in the diving.
Does your daughter do it just into it?
Yeah,
the triple pipe position near when that time Greg Lewis gain is banged his head
off the fucking,
the,
the board that that was,
that was the first epic fail before Youtube even existed.
Okay.
There was some gay guy diver who she had a problem with.
This junk would come flying out,
you know,
cause he had it so extras.
Fucking small evidently.
Or He's got a huge Dick.
Why are you talking about this fucking guy?
He said he's his manhood.
Would we be doing that?
A little fucking Twizzlers.
They're in the air,
whatever they call them.
He was gay.
He was gay man.
They said,
he said,
oh,
what is he gonna blow a guy in the platform as gay people?
They dive sometimes.
Some of them are architects.
When are you gonna open your mind up to the fact that gay people could do all
sorts of things?
She says,
what's it like to be married to a fascist?
Hey,
um,
oh,
speaking of fascist,
you know what's fucking hilarious?
I noticed over in Europe,
you get into a fascist come country and the elevators,
they don't play that game where it's starting to close and you stick your arm in
it.
They're just like on see what?
Too late.
And then he just like,
oh shit,
this isn't chop my fucking arm off.
You're in the allied countries,
right?
The elevator starts to close.
You can kind of do the all Aa easy.
They're easy.
I decide not you dude.
Fucking Germany and Italy.
I made the mistake two times.
I tried to do the,
Oh yeah,
let me stick my fucking arm in there.
And it quickly became like,
Whoa,
whoa.
I was barely able to get an a.
Actually,
it started to open again.
It does open back up,
but it's really aggressive,
really aggressive.
So anyways,
so went down there.
Okay,
Trey,
tell him about your girlfriend there did,
you couldn't stop fucking staring at
Jesus Christ.
So it was definitely a,
it was definitely,
what would you say near European cut fucking swimsuits.
Tribute to fucking Brazil.
Straight up g string at that beach.
Sun's out.
I know.
I like how you kept trying to suddenly catcher and your fucking videos.
Now I this,
yes you did.
You're a fucking Harvard,
but because you're a woman,
you won't get called on.
You are a creep and I kill you.
Go to sleep.
Yes you are.
She was just married and looking
and I appreciate it.
Anyway,
so I go to,
I got to go swim in.
I go to go swim in the fucking Mediterranean.
I go in there,
first of all the waters,
you know,
it's a little more choppy and I'm more of a pool guy.
Okay.
There's no current in a pool.
And um,
I went in there and Jesus Christ,
my fucking,
the second I put those fucking goggles on,
I looked down,
I saw these little fish swimming.
My brain leads,
it goes,
what's he,
what,
what he little fish.
Bigger fish,
right?
Like what's his face?
Uh,
Danny Devito in a one flew over the cuckoo's nest.
What do we do with these little fish?
And he smells,
he goes catch the big fish,
right?
And I just kept thinking bigger and bigger,
bigger fucking fish till I got the sharks.
And there was this little dad,
this little roped off area.
They had a little tarp there just in case one of these fucking monsters decided
to swim in.
But there was an open area because it was also bringing in these boats and I
just pictured one of them like looking over
because where I was,
you could see the bottom,
but if you looked the creepiest looked ever when you're in the ocean or a c is
like out to sea or out to the ocean where,
you know,
I'm glad you asked that in the end because that completely derails what the fuck
I'm talking about.
I don't know what they are.
They're both gigantic.
So anyways,
um,
when you look out and it gets into deeper water and just becomes a darker blue
and disappears,
I just kept picturing one of those sharks just coming into view doing that
little fucking,
you know,
sharks swim with their fucking asses moving.
It's like the old rollerblade impression.
I do.
Neo and the people would set up the cones and they'd turn around backwards and
the Ras would go was they went through the cones,
right?
That's how sharks swim.
Except they go frontwards.
I'm just picturing one of them fucking come in and
my heart was fucking racing.
Although you took video of me,
Neil was very impressed.
How I look when I swim.
I'm a good swimmer.
All freckles.
Two or 3 million people told you there's no sharks.
Okay,
well,
one time Carson told me and another person.
Okay,
now let's look this up.
let's look this up right now.
Sharks in the Mediterranean Sea in the where we are.
Oh yeah,
no,
I looked it up.
Like not only,
not only are they in the Mediterranean sees,
see the most attacks are off the coast of Italy.
So why are they all saying that there's no sharks?
Because this is a tourist trap near
where we're at is a fucking tourist trap.
Okay?
So they're just like that fucking guy.
He wants the beach is open and jaws.
Okay,
everybody's got to come down.
They've got to buy their magnets.
They gotta buy their fucking plates with lemons on it because this region is
known for lemon,
so everything has to have lemons on it.
But I,
I'm telling you that every five minutes.
Like I say,
the food,
the food is bad.
Outstanding when they'll lemme Naddis I've been crazy little slushies.
Right.
Or I need this.
Oh my God.
I'm going a good time.
What about that fucking dessert we had the other night that looked like a
fucking titty.
It was like,
it was like trace late Jake Cape,
but it was,
it was lemony and then on top of he had this cream and then for whatever reason,
yeah,
they put like this red look and something or other that look like a nipple.
Yeah.
It was a little milder.
It was delicious.
Who's the her now?
The second I said it look like a 10 year died.
Laughing is exactly what it looked like.
Not a real titty like a mannequin titty.
All right.
The 47 s the 47 shark species that lurk in the Mediterranean.
Okay.
And one of them.
Guess what?
It's the great white shark.
All right.
Shark attacks around the world map.
Let's look at this,
and when we all know in Australia,
someone gets taken as they say,
why we should worry,
why should we be worried about the rise in shark attacks?
I love how they're going to blame the sharks.
It's like maybe if we didn't fish out the ocean,
they'd have more food options.
You stupid cons.
A spike in shark attacks north and South Carolina's see one or two shark attacks
per year.
On average in the last month,
there have been eight.
No one has been killed,
but there is no such thing as a casual shoe.
I don't know what this is.
wait,
let me get to,
let me get back to the Mediterranean Sea.
MMM.
47 different types of species.
Where the fuck are they?
How to survive a shark attack?
Stay on the land.
All right.
European countries,
number of shark attacks since 1900 number of fatal attacks,
number one,
Nia,
Italy,
11 have been fatal.
So basically every year and a half or so,
probably a little bit less,
somebody gets bit by a shark.
Do you want to be that person?
I don't.
The UK had 38.
Nobody died.
Those tough pasty bastards spayed.
33,
seven people died.
You knew people would die.
This so dramatic there,
especially when they play soccer.
Croatia 25 and then 12 people died on half the people bit off probation.
Almost half of them die.
That's because it's so fucking much.
Or they probably tried to fight the thick set of getting out of there.
I must break you.
I have no idea what people in Croatia like,
just anybody in eastern Europe to me is,
uh,
is Dolph Lundgren.
Alright.
Grease.
24 attacks.
13 people died.
France,
ten three people died.
Portugal a one died.
Multa five,
three.
Jesus Christ.
Russia,
four zero.
Yeah.
You can't kill us best.
It's a Montenegro.
Three and two sharks found in the Mediterranean.
Angel Shark,
angular rough shark and cat Sherrod basking sharks.
Big eyed six sixgills shark.
Is that a nickname?
Big Guy Threat.
Let's just get to the ones that everybody knows.
Blue Sharks.
A dusky shark hammerhead.
Yeah,
there's a nice one.
they're real friendly.
Greg.
White sharks.
Okay.
Uh,
Maaco milk.
Sharp Notch Nurse Hound.
Okay.
Portuguese,
dogfish,
Sandbar Shark.
All right.
A lot of these I guess are not that intimidating or at least they haven't gotten
a shot.
Yeah,
I mean what if like the great white shark media is just like white people where
they get all the good roles in shark movies.
So that's why they made one about them.
And then all these other ones are like the minorities.
So no one ever hears about the sharp nose.
Seven Gill Shark.
What does that sound like to you as far as a person said Dominican rather,
listen to me.
Zip Up my luggage.
Then here you read off a list of sharks,
you know,
that's really me.
It's not supportive.
Huh?
Were you talking about,
he fucking said there's no sharps or shark attacks and there is any like,
boom,
the people here go so sure could tech.
What do you think they're going to say near you?
Think they're going to stand down.
They go on,
get out of the water.
Freaking everybody out.
I'm standing there and the Little Speedo,
oh Jesus Christ.
We saw some fucking people that needed to be in a bathing suit and we saw some
people that did not need,
did not need,
and I'd forgotten about that one guy.
And you fucking brought him up again at dinner.
Hairy ass.
Oh my good God.
All fucking mighty.
It's one of the most horrific fucking things I've ever seen.
A lot of hair.
Yeah.
He had like a taint afro coming out of the bottom of his fucking stupid ass
shorts just standing right in front of us.
It's like when you get,
did you say Taf?
Tafforeau
Ah,
God.
So anyways,
I've been out of the,
uh,
I've been out of the country for awhile and I found out from another American
here,
this guy from Chicago,
they're Milan.
Lou Cheech got traded to the Edmonton Oilers.
Fuck you.
I didn't know that you got a seven year contract,
you know,
they get some young talent over there.
So then I'm like,
well,
who did the brewing side like a fucking dope.
Like how many times do I have to get excited about who the Boston Bruins are
going to say?
I know who they're going to sign.
They're going to sign a bunch of fucking nobodies like they always do because
the ghosts to Harry sending still in there and they don't want to spend any
fucking money ever.
Can we ever go out and pick up a superstar?
We never do.
We always go out and get six really good people and then a couple of people like
who the fuck are they?
So we signed some fucking,
I dunno,
we signed some goaltender.
Yeah,
we signed this kid from St Louis.
He seem decent.
He scored 20 [inaudible] goals.
30 something goals at one point.
Well we ever signed a 50 goals score.
Nia.
Huh?
I hope so.
No,
never do that.
Pk Sue band comes along.
We ever going to fucking sign a guy like no.
The only time we get a guy like that is if we get lucky.
You know,
nobody knew fucking CIARA was.
No one knew who the fuck he was.
And when we sign him,
he was just this big six foot seven fucking goof tripping over himself in the,
in the,
in the capital of Canada up there in Ottawa.
Right.
And everybody up there and autumn weather is so God damn quiet and forgiving.
It's,
it's,
it's a transient fucking state.
Nobody's from Ottawa.
You go there and you try to push your legislation through to for the fucking
syrup bill,
whatever the fuck it is that people go do up there.
And they had no idea what this guy was.
And we got him and he was a steel,
I can't remember the last fucking time.
The Boston Bruins went out and signed a fucking sniper.
Okay.
I can tell you this.
So we,
we've given away more of those fucking guys in my life.
Joe Thornton.
Yeah.
Get the fuck out here at Tyler's Sag and get the fuck outta here.
Get the fuck Outta here.
That's what constantly sending 40 goal scorers.
Tell him to pack their bags.
And we always questioned that toughness.
Oh,
there's some rumor about their partying and it's fucking bullshit.
At the end of the fucking day,
you know what it is.
We don't want to pay him.
We don't want to pay him there.
I swear to God the Bruins ever went on fucking vacation.
If the franchise went on vacation,
they,
they'd rent a fucking trailer.
That's what they would do.
Wow.
Of all,
why should we pay for a fucking hotel room?
You know,
this is,
this keeps us driving,
but one more fucking
when brains out in has a roof.
I can't remember last time I was excited about anybody they fucking sign,
but,
but every fucking summer I'm like,
we got rid of that guy.
How under the fucking are we?
I don't have any of these fucking numbers,
by the way.
I have no idea.
I just don't understand.
Like fucking,
okay.
See you.
The sabers site and see Kyle a poser.
I don't know the Pozo or no idea this guy is,
I have no idea where any of these fucking people are.
Maybe that's what it is.
Maybe I should shut the fuck up is I don't know who anybody is anymore.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Calgary flames signed a bunch of nobodies.
Ah,
who gives a shit?
I have these fucking people didn't,
you know,
cause he's fucking European stop coming into the league with their Goddamn
Transylvanian names.
Even if they're good.
I mean they have to score like 900 goals before you finally know how to say
their name.
At least me anyways.
Oh good.
Did you sign Jordan to too?
That's a name.
T.
O.
Okay.
You know,
if he scores a bunch of goals they'll say Jordan was too,
too much for the fucking who gives a shit last night.
Sorry.
All right,
let's get to the,
um,
yeah,
let's get to some of the reeds here for the week.
MMM.
All right,
here we go.
Uh Oh,
the Tim Ferriss show.
Everybody,
uh,
did you guys know the Tim Ferriss show was selected as one of iTunes best of two
to 2015 I just said to,
to like that guy,
the podcast has been downloaded by more than 80 million people or 80 million
times.
And in each episode,
Tim,
deconstruct world class performers from every walk of life,
business sports at investing in more to find the tools,
tactics,
and routines you can use.
Favorite books,
check boring routines.
Check in.
That's just the beginning.
Past guests include Arnold Schwartzenegger.
What was that story?
What's his face told Bill Hader.
Remember that near
Carl weathers.
He ate the Schnitzel,
a Laird Hamilton and serial billionaire.
Peter Thiel,
serial billionaire with he fucking killing people.
The stories are captivating and the lessons will help you upgrade your life.
Just visit four hour workweek.com/tim,
that's four hour workweek.com.
MMM.
F O U R H O.
U R Jesus Christ.
Workweek forward slash Tim.
Yeah.
Case you don't have to spell four hour.
Um,
so I guess he interviews a bunch of successful people and then uh,
they give you their secrets and then you apply them to your life.
And next thing you know whose,
whose face is on the cover of the cereal box.
Oh,
I think that show.
Alright.
Helix.
Everybody Helux you're,
you're unique.
You don't walk like everyone else talk like everyone else.
So sleep like everyone,
you don't go to a baseball game and sit in the bleachers and no one has any
fucking idea whether you're there or not.
You're special.
So,
so why is your mattress one size fits all you stand out in the crowd is you sit
there and your sweat pants eating a slice of pizza in Manhattan.
They made that city for you.
So why are you sleeping on a mattress that is made for your average run of the
mill fucking animal?
I know why.
I don't know why,
but this next line explains why.
Because a truly customized mattress will cost you five to 10,000 bucks until
now.
Is that how much they cost?
Well,
I guess that's why I sleep on a regular mattress.
Why would you spend five to 10 grand on something?
You just gonna.
You know you're not even gonna remember being on it.
Jesus Christ.
Five [inaudible].
What would you do with five to $10,000?
Oh,
she has her headphones on.
She can't hear me.
Nia,
I'm way smarter than you.
You're a dumb person.
And you lucked out when you met me.
Hey Sweetie,
how you doing?
You're so gorgeous.
And everyone in the podcast message.
No,
you didn't go to go to helix.
Sleep dot.
Tom.
Answer a few simple questions.
And the helots smart guy,
Alex,
and they'll run it.
Is it?
Yes.
Oh my God.
How do you know?
Because that's how the word is.
Now,
how do I know there was a fucking band?
There was a ban in the 80s called Helix.
I guarantee you bill,
it's not the pronunciation of the abandoned the eighties and no one's fucking
heard of.
Well,
you're in a mode,
Huh?
Dota Helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple questions and they'll run a three d biomechanical
model of your yeah.
Body through the proprietary algorithms they developed with the help of the
world's leading irrigant nomics and biomechanics experts.
All I knew no is they just need a,
you know,
at this,
this is what this side businesses,
they take this computer mold to your body,
right?
So they figured out what kind of mattress should do and then they sell the mold
to Asia and they make those fucking sex suits.
And then there's somebody over there fucking the,
the the mattress version of you.
That's what they,
that's what they're doing over there and it's an issue of national security.
That's why we need to elect Trump.
Do you know over in Asia
are fucking a cadaver version of yourself right now they're laughing at us and
they're charging us to do it.
Okay.
If I became president,
there would be no more Asians fucking mattress versions of Americans,
but I try and make it great again.
Yeah,
well,
track or dozer work,
I could grow it again.
The result,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
Helix customers report a 30% improvement in overall sleep quality.
How do you even realize that you're asleep and for couples they customize each
side of the mattress.
What do you have better dreams.
Your mattress arrives at your door in about a week and shipping is 100% free
with them.
If they take a fucking moldy a body and they crank it out that fast.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine to Forbes are all talking about helix
sleep.
You have a hundred nights to try it out roast,
and if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free and give you 100% refund.
No questions,
AG,
so go to [inaudible] dot com slash burn and get $50 off your order.
That's he likes sleep.com/bird hey helic sleep.com/burr he lists you go.
He links since the peanut gallery.
Oh Nini.
It's one of my favorite reads ever.
It's time for roles.
Zip Recruiter.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
Oh No.
You want to find the perfect hire.
You need to post your job on all the top job sites,
man,
and now you can with zip.
Well bruta.com you can post your job to 100 plus job sites,
including social media networks like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click clip.
Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll into zip.
Easy to use.
Interface.
No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates,
rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why zip
has been used by over 1 million businesses.
Right now.
My listeners can post jobs on zip recruiter by going to ziprecruiter.com/burr
that's ziprecruiter.com/bird one more time.
Try it and go to try it for free.
Sorry,
and go to sip.
Okay.
recruiter.com/ [inaudible] all right.
Yeah.
One more.
Mercifully one more.
And the empty watches when you're in your early twenties and thirties money can
be tight if you're not careful.
Dressing well can quickly drain your bank account like spending four to $500 on
the departments.
Do our watch.
Okay.
There's some brands out there charging insane prices for watches that aren't
even worth it.
Well,
if you want to look great when you go out,
but still have money to buy him or her a drink,
where the fuck is buying a guy at drink?
Jesus fucking Christ.
Checkout movement.
watches.co I know the gay divers who's junk come out when they spin around.
Well,
Shit,
if your Dick's coming off,
there's no way you're fucking watch isn't going to fly off,
right?
Yeah.
I want to think you make a watch for that guy who's Dick comes out.
Um,
checkup movement watches Todd comp.
All right.
Originally founded by two broke college kids.
Not to be confused by two broke girls,
which I started watching with Nia and I can't even begin to tell you how
soothing both of their voices are.
I swear to God,
if you head on a movement watch while watching two broke girls,
I would,
I would not be surprised if it during the punchlines and they'd started to come
apart.
Um,
all right.
Originally founded by two broke college kid movement watches cut out the
middlemen and their big brand retail markups in order to give you a stylish
watch for an affordable price movement,
watches start at just $95.
A watch with departments to equality for a fraction of the price is sleek and
minimalistic and modern twist on a classic style.
But it has grown organically purely by support is like you.
So join there more than 1 million social media followers and get a movement
watched today.
People are following watches on social media.
Go to Mvmt,
watches.com/burr and they'll give you a 15% off your entire purchase.
MVMT watches Michael Vincent,
Michael Thomas,
watches.com/ [inaudible]
okay.
All right,
let's get back to the podcast.
Hey,
what are you doing on the Internet?
Oh,
I follow this watch company that just can't get enough of it.
My favorite days is when they have a new watch that comes out and I get to see
how they attach the strap to the face.
Oh,
really?
That's,
that makes me never want to talk to you again.
Well,
that's,
maybe that's the deal.
Maybe that's the brilliance of it.
That's a good thing to say on a first date and then you don't want to be the
Dick to say you don't want to have a second date.
Maybe you invite her up for a second day going,
hey,
you want to fucking come over to my apartment in,
watch the goings on.
Of MVMT watches online.
Yeah.
If you just shut up right then.
Okay.
And you really listen.
You can hear it drain up across the table.
Oh,
Bill,
that's disgusting.
Oh,
is it?
Well,
I'm sorry you're not an adult.
here's something I came across on the Internet,
so you know,
it's gotta be true.
I'm just going through all these countries and shit.
I don't even know how I got there.
Like each night I come home,
I'm totally like,
you know,
I'm asleep.
I've had a couple glasses of wine and the next morning I wake up when I see the
windows that I'm open to going.
When the fuck was I looking at that?
Like,
for some reason I went,
I started reading up on Leon Spinks.
MMM.
Oh,
you know why?
I know why?
Cause I fucking,
the other night I was watching,
uh,
when,
George Foreman fought Ron Lyle and I got to tell you what's his,
it's like a rocky fight,
right?
Howard Cosell,
Howard Cosell is in rare form.
He just shits on everybody.
The fight starts and he goes,
ah,
lunging almost amateur wrist,
right hand from the challenger for Ron Lyle and whoever the fuck he's doing the
fight with,
he can't think it's Ken Norton.
He reminds him like seven times during that fight that George Foreman knocked
him out.
I thought at one point that what's his face was going to punch out.
He just never gave into it.
But he just goes,
I would not describe this as an artistic endeavor or something,
a boxing exit exposition.
This is not,
you've got to watch it.
It's an incredible fight.
But anyway,
so,
um,
last night I started,
uh,
I dunno,
maybe I was reading about Quentin Tarantino and I got into fucking,
uh,
inglorious bastards.
And I don't know if this is true or not,
but evidently after the fucking war,
right,
and the world saw what the fucking Nazis did.
They were like,
well,
someone's got to pay for this.
They had the Nuremberg trials and all they did was they basically,
I dunno,
it's an amount of,
do about 24 individuals,
God punished,
some got life imprisonment,
some got put to death,
the whatever.
And they say it takes more than 24 people to kill 6 million,
obviously.
Right.
So basically the amount of the fucking headache it was to bring these guys to
trial and go through all the bullshit and put together the cases.
They just said that that's it.
That's too fucking big.
There's too many God damn.
People were also carving up the con country and we need these cuts to work for
us.
So the allies kind of washed their hands of it.
At which point?
Um,
some hardcore fucking Jewish people.
The uh,
w what's,
what's that Matt Damon character near,
he comes out with it every once in a while he had the gun in the fucking lady
was like,
get the gun out of the poster because that's what makes people use guns.
Jason Bourne.
That was one of the dumbest things I've ever seen in my life.
Get that gun off of that movie poster.
Yeah,
that'll solve the problem.
That's what it was.
I remember when Star Wars came out and all these little kids went out and got
the fucking light sabers and all that shit.
I mean,
good for that person,
fairly taking the time to really address the issue and not make it about
themselves.
Um,
alright,
plowing ahead here.
So this group of a Jason Bourne,
Jewish people got together and they're like,
you know what?
I don't think I'm satisfied with 24 of these nuts.
He counts going down.
And then allegedly they were like,
this fucking hit squad going around the fucking world.
Just fuck tracking these fucking people down.
And uh,
haven't kangaroo court trials in fucking executing them.
Um,
I don't know if the shit is true.
It was such an amazing fucking story that I can't believe that if it was
actually true,
why this wouldn't have seen the light of day.
These guys actually went to the point,
one person,
they said they showed up to eat,
killed over 100,000 fucking people and they gave him a,
a rope.
All right.
And they let him,
do they say that and let him do the dcis?
Yeah.
Was it Elkins describes how,
for example,
I'm going to fuck all these words up.
The no men track down.
Okay.
To suburban Winnipeg,
Canada.
One Alexander lack responsible for the deaths of 100,000 Jews at the Estonian
concentration camp.
They waited for lax wife to leave on a cinema trip.
You mean go to the movies,
then confronted him with the crimes and their intended punishment and let him do
the decent thing and take his own life with the rope.
What deaf and what do they stage it like?
He was jerking off.
I gotta look this guy up.
They were one point we're going to try to poison the fucking water and just
indiscriminately kill a bunch of fucking German people that the same way that
they had killed a bunch of Jewish people.
Um,
okay.
I want to know why.
Why?
There hasn't been a bunch of shit talking about this.
If this actually happened.
Me Look,
this guy,
what the fuck's his name again?
Alexander lack.
Okay.
Alexander lack what's,
look this guy up.
Let's see if his wife went to go visit the cinema and he took his own life with
the fucking,
okay.
No,
but then they said that they all did it and they kept their mouth shut about it.
So then how the fuck would I know about it?
But then again,
somebody took the time to type it,
so like,
doesn't that mean it happened?
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Yeah.
All right.
Jesus.
Doesn't these guys all look fucking evil?
Yeah.
A concentration camp commander,
he's got a Wikipedia page,
was the lieutenant and the commander,
the German occupation of Astonia,
the estimates for number of Jews killed is widely varied.
Uh,
the Soviet investigators reached the conclusion that two to 3000 were killed,
but God knows they didn't like juice.
So that's probably add a zero to all of that at least.
Uh,
but the number 5,000 as determined by extraordinary state commission,
1944 was written into verdict in modern sources.
The number is 10,000.
Some commentators have also given figures ranging from a hundred thousand to
125,000 to 300,000.
However,
such figures contradict the findings in the stonier.
Blahblahblahblahblah Alexander lack was also known to have a range drunken
orgies with inmates.
Ah,
Jesus.
He emigrated to Canada after World War II in 1948 and 1960 was implicated in the
holocaust trials in Soviet dystonia and exposed as living in a naturalized
citizen under the name Alex lack in Winnipeg,
Canada.
Okay.
Thereafter,
after reading of arrests of young Vic Ralph Perez from mass killing him,
mostly jurors dream sage while under Nazi ossification and being himself
identified as a mass murder.
He apparently committed suicide by hanging himself in the garage of his home at
53 Ah,
Israeli journalist claimed at LACC was in fact confronted one day after his wife
had left their house to go to the movies.
All right,
so this indiscriminate website that I have no idea if it's true or not lines up
with his Wikipedia page.
So I'm going to say,
I want to say this is true
and I want to,
is there a book I can read on this?
Who doesn't like a good vengeance story?
Okay,
that's amazing.
And just coming up on these fucking creeps they had to have known when you do
some shit like that,
you got every night when you got to be looking at down the driveway,
even if you were in the middle of fucking Winnipeg,
but if ever you would ever feel safe,
you'd think Winnipeg.
I gotta go fucking,
what the fuck's going to go to Winnipeg?
You know,
Thunder Bay yellow knife.
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Man,
that's gotta be a rough one.
I said,
say he did that.
Let's just say he killed two to 3000 people and forced them half orgies.
When you're taking your own life,
you've gotta be thinking like,
please God,
don't let the be evil.
If you said God,
you believe in it,
I'd be like,
please don't let there be an afterlife cause I am going,
I'm going to the basement there.
Alright,
that's the podcast.
Just checking in on you guys.
Um,
don't get everybody that's listening.
By the way,
I took over near snapchat yesterday.
Um,
I don't know if it's going to disappear by then.
Uh,
I had sort of a good time doing it.
I hated the whole fucking thing I hit on yet 10 seconds to say what the fuck he
had to say that that was annoying.
What'd you say?
Yeah.
Why should I do it again?
People love it.
Once you get into the feel of it will be really great at.
Um,
yeah,
but I mean,
I could probably say the same thing about changing a tire,
but I don't want to be a fucking AAA guy.
Right.
That made no sense.
Okay.
That's it for the checking in on you.
A joy.
This little music here and uh,
then we'll give you some greatest hits from Monday morning.
Pause.
Cat's gone by.
As always,
if you'd like to contribute to this podcast,
but don't want to spend any money.
If you ever go to Amazon going,
hey,
I think I'm going to buy myself a craftmatic adjustable bed.
Just go by the bill burr website first bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page is an Amazon link.
Okay.
It'll take you right to Amazon.
It doesn't cost you any extra money.
I just get credit for driving traffic there.
Okay.
If you'd like to do what?
I appreciate it.
If you don't,
I understand.
Have a great weekend and I'll talk to you on Monday then.
All right.
Gil Dead.
Okay.
Oh,
hey,
what's up?
It's still bar.
Uh,
this is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August the 18th.
And uh,
this is my second,
my second time recording this podcast.
I did one this morning from Miami International Airport and uh,
there was some sort of tropical storms,
so I dunno what the fuck happened.
I babbled for a half an hour.
I said fuck a lot.
It was a woman looked like she was a mother.
She was two seats away from me.
I felt bad,
but I continued to plow through it because it was a good podcast and then I went
to save it in the fucking thing.
Didn't save.
I don't know what happened.
I think that everybody was trying to dial out because it was a tropical storm,
which basically means,
oh my God,
it's,
it's raining.
No,
it's,
it's like really rain.
If it's like seriously raining to fucking tropical storm,
I don't know.
You know what I mean?
I got off the plane and I saw some news clips of it,
you know,
they always show the deepest puddle,
you know what I mean?
Then they try and act like a,
the whole place is like that.
So anyways,
I'm sitting in my Prius,
uh,
down the street from my apartment right now because,
I was going to go out and get tasks and then I realized they have a new law,
you know,
that you can't drive around with your fucking cell phone up to your ear or you
get a ticket,
you know.
So,
uh,
you know what,
I really had an urge to get rims on my car.
You know,
these,
uh,
I dunno if you guys are all familiar with the Prius.
Looks like it's basically,
it's the fucking greatest car in the world.
I totally recommend it.
If you want to point a to point B,
you know,
you don't want any whores hanging on.
Yeah,
this is the car.
No,
I'm serious,
man.
It's a fucking great car.
The only thing that sucks about it is it has these little breath saver fucking
tires and rims and it's,
it's starting to affect my manhood.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
you know,
and this isn't even like,
who's got the biggest dick kind of thing.
It's just more of a,
you know,
you don't want to have training wheels on your car,
for fucking training wheels.
So I think I can get eighteens on these.
Fuck you.
It's respectable.
The hybrid or right.
That's equal to whatever you got on your fucking SUV.
We didn't have makes you more of a man.
Ooh,
I got a big fucking truck.
Like I couldn't afford that least that given those things away,
I could,
I could drive one and a half without a fucking suburban right now if I want it
to.
I just choose not to.
This is a choice.
All right.
Do you know what I'm saying?
It's really affecting,
it's affecting myself esteem.
Anyways.
If you new to my page,
if you're still on my space and you haven't defected to fucking Facebook,
which by the way,
I guess when you fill out the information thing over there,
the list,
the reason why I'm not on it,
if you decide to be like,
hey,
fuck Facebook in the future,
um,
they'll like,
well,
hey,
fuck you.
You can't delete your page.
We'll take the page off and we'll keep all the personal information about you.
And I don't know what they're gonna do with it.
And that gets my conspiracy fucking head going.
And the funny thing is,
is I've never looked at the small print,
but my space,
whether they do the shit too,
but,
uh,
I don't know what's going on here.
It's all leading towards the microchip in the back of your fucking head,
I'm telling you.
But,
uh,
anyways,
if you do it on my page,
I do one of these every fucking week,
sometimes twice a week.
If there's a tropical storm,
I'm in the airport that I'm in.
Um,
basically last week I worked the Improv in Miami,
Florida.
I had a great time and I gotta tell you,
man,
Miami is,
that's just the town that you're supposed to fucking,
I can't even,
I can't even explain it.
It's just the hottest fucking women I've ever seen in my life.
It's,
you know what it is?
it's like a city that's moving forward so it has that energy,
but then it also has that laid back Caribbean vibe and all these fucking hot ass
Cuban women walking around,
whatever the fuck you want.
It's walking around down there
with a fat ass and thick size and that God damn half a dress on.
It's ridiculous.
You literally have to rub one out before you leave your fucking apartment for
the comedy Condo,
whatever the Hell I was staying,
just so you can get to the damn comedy club.
So,
uh,
I had a good time down there.
I definitely had a good fucking time.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
you know what,
I actually quit drinking when I was down there cause I went out Thursday night
and it's just,
uh,
I met up with this couple who I partied with before and they didn't know that
wasn't drinking whiskey anymore because as I've said,
another podcast,
it's the fucking devil juice.
So after the show they had,
they had a Jamison set up for me and I didn't want to be rude.
Cause when you don't accept the drink from people,
sometimes they,
you know,
they get a little psycho like that dude and Columbus.
You know what I'm talking about guys,
the funny bone and fucking freaked out when I wouldn't drink the drink.
Um,
yeah,
they get all like,
oh well what do you,
what are you too big?
You're too big now.
Oh you,
you can't,
you can't drink the fucking,
I'm not drinking asshole.
We Times I've got to say,
I appreciate you coming out to my show.
It took a picture with you.
I signed the fucking CD.
I listen to you tell me some stories.
Well,
what else do I gotta do?
I gotta get a NIB related with you.
So anyways,
that was the dude in Columbus and to do with a couple of Miami,
so whatever.
So they gave me a Jamison.
I drank that Jamieson,
of course you've got to wash it down with a Budweiser.
And then I find out the dude manages a bar and you can get free drinks and then
it's fucking on.
Okay.
And I remember going into the bar,
but I don't remember leaving and I had to do radio the next day,
so
I'm just too fucking old to be doing it.
So I,
I,
I'm on the wagon.
I'm not like fucking going to meetings or anything.
Like I'm taking a break.
You know what I mean?
You don't want to get to that point your life where you're just like,
wow,
am I in this room again?
Am I really,
really the fucking chick with the red wine breadth is now breathing.
Really.
This is happening again.
Again.
Oh,
the guy on coke,
this room.
I've been in this room.
I hate this room.
How many fucking times am I going to walk in here before I realized I,
you know,
stupid.
[inaudible]
all right.
Anyways,
so anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
I answered questions.
I got a new segment on here called underrated overrated that people are really
responding to.
Um,
and it's basically you just send me your list of stuff that you see in life or
on television and pop culture and your own personal life.
Can you send me your list of Shit that you think is underrated or overrated?
I even know how this fucking segment started.
It was really organic,
which is why I like it and people are actually very rarely even sending me
questions anymore.
They're just more kind of sending these lists of shit here.
But before I get into that,
now that I've already babbled for fucking eight minutes,
eight seconds,
uh,
let me just,
let me just whore myself out really quickly.
Um,
if you look at the top of my page,
I have a new special coming out called,
why do I do this?
It's going to be on comedy central August 31st at 11:00 PM.
I got to put that in the graphic.
I also filmed the youtube video hyping the special.
That should be up on the page later on this week and up on Youtube.
Um,
I don't want to,
don't want to tell you what it's called because I don't want to give away the
joke or whatever the whole fucking thing is.
But,
uh,
I got that going on and I'll be at the stress factory in New Jersey on September
29th,
30th and 31st.
So I'll be back in the New York area,
which means I will be doing the opening and Anthony Show radio program,
the best fucking show out there that I really missed doing.
The only fucking thing that I miss about a needle work is doing that show and
hanging out with those guys.
So I'm really psyched that we,
I think I'll be on there Thursday of that week,
if not Thursday and Friday.
I have no idea.
Um,
and that's all.
Next m two o two bro.
You punks in the middle of nowhere.
All right,
so that's it.
So with that,
let's get to the,
uh,
let's get to the podcast questions.
We'll do those first because the underrated overrated is really fucking long.
Uh,
let's see.
Question,
uh,
a bill.
Uh,
Damn.
That dude's got that fucking,
can you hear that?
It's one of those guys who listens to hip hop and you can't figure out why they
listen to it.
Add the fuck.
I guess I listened to it,
but I have the thesis.
He to put the windows up.
You know what I mean?
If you're nerdy looking white dude like me and you listen to hip hop,
put the fucking windows up.
Okay.
Cause I just looked over and I thought it was going to see 50 cent and I didn't,
I saw
his name was probably Chris.
Actually,
wait a minute.
Isn't that fucking 50 cents?
Really know what the fuck is his real name?
Curtis Curtis Jackson.
Christopher Wallace is biggie smalls.
That should be a trivia question on like jeopardy.
I'll take rappers real names for a 200.
You know what?
I really wished I had a fucking rappers real name.
Uh,
I answered to the name Shawn Carter in the fucking early nineties.
I believe.
Jay Z.
Uh,
go fuck yourself for 100.
All right.
Here we go.
The podcast questions for uh,
for the week of August 18th with NF.
All right,
Bill.
I recently discovered the entertainment value of going on to youtube and doing a
search for awful comedian or comedian bombing.
They're basically videos were comics and doing eight to 10 minutes sets.
They're not getting a single laugh,
not even a pity laugh.
And my favorite part is seeing how they deal with it.
If I were ever to do an open mic and bomb like I know I would,
is it better to just ignore what you and everyone in the room knows namely how
Shitty I am or just play it off.
It's no,
it's you,
you have to address it.
You have to address it.
That is page one of doing standup comedy.
Whatever's happening in the room,
you have to address it unless it's really small,
you know what I mean?
If somebody says something or drops a glass of does some bullshit and only like
that section here is it,
and you're on a roll,
don't address it because then you,
then you start talking to somebody and the people in the back didn't hear it and
then it just,
it becomes a cluster fuck.
So yeah,
if you start bombing,
yeah,
just to dress it,
just say anything,
you know,
I suck.
I knew this was going to suck.
I'll never do that joke again.
Wow.
That hurt.
Uh,
I can't feel my pancreas.
Whatever you can,
you know,
just really,
you know what?
Go with honesty.
Don't do those,
those fucking,
those,
uh,
those memorize lines.
Like,
hey buddy,
do I go down to the bus station on Ls heckle?
Did I answer that last week?
This,
these fucking things are starting to overlap.
All right.
Yeah.
So if you go up on stage and you start bombing,
definitely address it.
Okay.
If you address it,
it,
it gives people hope that you're,
that you're somehow a human being and you're aware,
but when you just fucking plow through it,
you really can get in trouble.
A white crowd,
suburban white crowd,
they're actually going to feel worse than you and they're going to start staring
at the fucking floor.
They can't even look at other people at that table.
They're so uncomfortable with that type of shit.
You know what I mean?
Because they're in that world of fucking smiling there in the Truman show,
you know,
the empty pursuit of knickknacks and always acting like,
hi,
how are you?
Everything's great.
So when they actually see a fucking painful moment that they can not smooth over
with an awkward laugh,
then they fucking,
they just stare at the floor.
If you're in front of more of a white trash redneck crowd,
you're going to get heckled.
Fuck's wrong with you buddy.
Why don't you bring on the next mother fucker?
And then you go to def con five,
which is a black crowd.
And what I've learned,
uh,
which I might've mentioned in past podcasts,
they're all starting to overlap.
I've learned what the black crowd they're going to have fun with or without you.
That's what I learned.
So either you bring it and they laugh with you or you don't.
And then when your joke bombs,
there's a 1.5 second pause of silence and then everybody laughs because nobody
laughed.
And then
then whatever,
I dunno how many minutes you got left and you set,
but it's going to seem like the rest of your life.
And
you know,
I think I just broke up in cold sweats thinking about that.
I really had some fucking rough ones.
Um,
okay.
Next question.
Uh,
Bill,
uh,
here's one for you.
When was the last time bill burr had to,
had to thrown the fisticuffs had to thrown fisticuffs when's the last time you
fucking learn how to write a sentence?
I think he was trying to say,
don't.
When's the last time you had to throw fists?
Uh,
when was the last time you,
what is the proper way to use fisticuffs?
We're involved in some fisticuffs,
a little Donny brook sky guy.
Sounds like a drunk 60 year old.
He's using fucking phrases from the 1920.
Alrighty.
I was the last time I had to,
I don't know,
like fucking fought my brother and a red roof fan above.
I was like 35 so it's five years ago.
I didn't fight him.
I just tied him up cause I'm older and more mature and I didn't want to do that.
You know what I mean?
And before that,
I think the last fight I had was with my same brother probably during the grunge
era.
It was a
right as the smashing pumpkins were,
had their big breakthrough album.
And just right after that and just before Kurt Cobain killed himself.
All right.
Underrated.
Overrated.
Um,
let's see,
what do we got here for this week?
All right.
Here's this one guy's list.
This is his list for underrated.
He said the Camaro.
It's one bad ass car.
I don't know how the fuck you think a legendary American muscle car,
like the Camaro is underrated.
I mean,
they're fucking bringing it back.
That car was the shift from the late six sixties right through to like 87 88 and
then it kind of became a joke.
You know the f body,
the only one that I think is underrated is,
is the one from like the late seventies you know the smoking,
abandoned design,
but the Camaro version,
not the trans-am member and there was three of them.
They had the sport troop,
the Berlinetta and the fucking z 28 and the Berlinetta was the middle one.
I think he got a decent engine.
But you had these grand granny fucking wire rims on it.
I Dunno.
All right.
More underrated shit.
This guy thinks doing an iron cross in gymnastics is underrated.
I can't tell you how many times they did an iron cross and people are like,
ah,
whatever.
I could fucking do that guys list starting off week.
But I like this one.
He says,
you who is underrated,
you know that chocolate he'd drink?
He's like,
look at the nutritional facts.
It's not bad for you.
Who fucking knew the iron,
the umbrella doc Martins,
a good promotional pen.
Ever had a pen from someplace called Gust is bathroom fixtures that lasted you
for three years.
Three years.
The fucker was in the fucker was free.
You know what?
Uh,
yeah.
I got one from a fucking dental office that I've been using for the last six
years,
but it's on my desk and I type a lot,
so I dunno.
Email Corey Feldman guy.
Thanks.
Corey Feldman is underrated.
Any claims,
the fucker never made a bad movie and to defend that argument,
these are the movies he lifts.
Gremlin's Goonies.
Stand by me.
I'll give you that.
That's a good one.
Lost Boys lost.
First of all,
lost boys suck.
Okay.
Lost Boyz was good when it came out and I was fucking 1819 years old,
but it did not hold up over time.
You know what I mean?
With those feathered fucking mullets that everybody had,
those things suck gremlins and Goonies.
I never even saw those a kitty movies.
I guess.
If you're a kid,
okay,
I'll give you,
they didn't stock book.
Come on man.
You know what you did in port about the one that he and he ended with that
dream,
a little dream of me,
and he did his Michael Jackson soft.
You tap dance at the end of the movie.
That movie sucked and you conveniently conveniently did not bring that up,
but you know what is overrated?
His drug use.
I saw a thing about him.
He only was fucked up for about two years,
but it followed them forever and that's the reason why young guns too.
He says,
oh,
really?
Have you ever watched a Clint Eastwood,
John Wayne,
if you know the magnificent seven?
Have you ever watched a real cowboy movie?
Why don't you watch one of those fucking movies and input on young guns too?
All right,
with fucking Lou Diamond Phillips and Emilio Estefan,
Jesus Christ,
all right.
More underrated stuff from other people eating at home instead of out,
even if you're eating shit,
feel more satisfying and the cheaper 90% of the time.
I says Psi Phi horror movies from the seventies and eighties
okay,
what did he say?
Oh yeah,
Robo cop in the fly before they had all these psycho fucking,
all these psycho.
Speaking of psycho,
I'm literally sitting here in the car,
right?
And I'm staring at my laptop in two people just walk by looking at me like,
what the fuck is this guy's problem?
Is he homeless?
Is he another struggling actor around here?
You know,
I didn't do this guy's,
this guy's underrated thing.
Justice here,
he said Sci fi horror movies of the 70s and eighties most of the more recent
computer affect affect heavy films of this.
John Rhe Pale in comparison to intelligently made movies with Realistic Gore and
affects like robocop on the fly Robo Cup on the fly with the shit.
And I know what you say it.
You know what a great example.
This isn't Scifi,
but that movie a perfect storm.
That movie,
the book is unbelievable.
The movie sucks.
The whole movie,
you're just waiting for the fucking wave and that's it.
Other than that,
they didn't develop the characters and I didn't give a fuck about anybody in it.
And I liked George Clooney and Mark Walberg and the guy who played the creepy
fishermen.
I liked him too.
It was John C and neck.
I can't remember this guy says hand jobs are overrated.
There were a lot of factors with sex.
He can,
it can often not live up to expectations.
I find myself concentrating too hard on enjoying myself during blowjobs.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
This isn't not doctor drew,
I've just breaking your balls.
But that was,
yeah,
I don't know how to make that funny on it.
Concentrating too hard to enjoy myself.
You start making those noises.
She just want the hand job.
You know something.
A lot of women,
you know something,
there's a lot of women out there don't do not know how to give a fucking hand
job and it's not their fault.
The same way.
There's a lot of women out there sitting there like I am a guy really doesn't
know how to go down on him.
That's not his fault.
You got to communicate.
So you know,
teach a girl how to rub one out.
Oh God,
what am I talking about?
You know what?
As I get the windows up cause I'm cursing and it started to get fucking hot in
here.
Maybe it was that less suggestion.
A Seltzer water
is a beverage of gods.
Think about it is water,
but it's kind of like soda.
You know what?
I'm not going to think about it.
Oh that's right.
You get to see you get someone you closed and it takes the stain out.
I don't fucking know.
Popeye's is overrated.
Underrated Upright Citizens Brigade.
I never watched that show.
It would just see a show and you just don't want to watch it.
You can't even figure out why.
It was one of those shows.
It's kind of like Tim Allen tool time.
The second I saw the set second,
I saw the couch on that show.
I was just like,
I don't want to watch this.
I have no idea whether that's a good show or a bad show.
I have no fucking clue.
Um,
all right,
let's get into overrated because he thinks are really getting long and I feel
like I'm just reading down when this isn't even funny.
Alright.
Overrated.
Broadway musicals,
techno music,
Japanese baseball players.
Do.
That's fucking great.
Whoever wrote that.
That's great.
They are overrated.
The decky met sue.
We remember when he first came over here,
what would they say?
Godzilla.
Like he was going to hit 800 fucking home runs.
He is definitely a fundamentally sound player,
but you know,
I mean he's,
he's good,
but he was the,
he was supposed to be the best Japanese player available at the time.
He's definitely the best Udekki whoever played in the league because you
remember the other one,
the Yankees had member that had decky.
You'll Rabo came over.
He came over here.
Who's the fat one?
Laurel Hardy.
He looks like the Japanese version of the fat one.
He just,
he and the magnets on his wrist,
he fucking stunk.
All those fucking Yankee fans had the rising sun fucking bed and is on their
heads like he was going to keep the,
uh,
well I guess they kept the dynasty going anyways,
but he sure as heck did he get a ring.
Does anybody know?
Could somebody else answer that?
Whether he got a ring or not,
who else is in each hero?
But there wasn't a lot of hype with each hero,
but he has a Japanese baseball player.
He's the shit.
But that other guy,
cosmetic Zooey.
I mean,
you know,
he bleach blonde is Harry end up looking like that guy always wins that Nathan's
hot dog eating contest.
All right.
I'm being a dick now.
Blackberry phones.
Modern Art,
someone said is overrated.
Yeah,
I'd have to say it's over ready to,
I don't like looking at something.
I got to figure out what the fuck it is.
You know what I mean?
I get it on a certain level,
but it's a lot of times it's like,
dude,
you just sort of threw a bunch of paint on there.
Um,
on demand.
Television is overrated cause the shit hardly ever works.
Jesus Christ.
It's one of the truest things I ever heard.
I got to agree with that one.
I have really bad cable,
uh,
Mexican restaurants.
It's eating fast food with silverware.
You know what?
That's fucked up.
I gotta say that's fucked up.
You know why?
Because there's too many Mexican restaurants out there owned by white people,
and there's something about Mexican food that you just gotta.
You just throw a bunch of cheese on it and you use those fucking,
uh,
those,
whatever they,
uh,
the fuck in the round things and you'll get it.
You know how to roll it up.
People can just say it's Mexican food.
Taco bell ruined Mexican food.
That has to be some good Mexican restaurants out there.
He can't fucking shit on an entire country's food.
Like nobody in Mexico knows how to cook,
um,
all to speak to that.
On the flight back from Miami,
there was two Italian guys literally from Italy who was such so fucking loud.
It made me never want to go to Italy and I've always wanted to be there.
I've always wanted to go there.
They would like characters from a movie.
They were speaking Italian as loud as you play.
Yeah.
Well,
the whole fucking flight and one of these fat fucking bastards.
The other guy was skinny.
Other guy was fat.
Right.
Speaking of Laurel and hardy,
he kept hitting the woman's chair next to me.
He had his foot up in between the window in her seat at one point.
And I,
you know,
you have a,
just want to be like a invade someone's body,
so they'll,
they'll do what you want them to do.
Kind of like Whoopi Goldberg and ghosts.
That's what I wanted to do.
Somehow morphed into her body and then take a pen and just stab that guy right
the bottom of his bucket.
You fucking
Dick.
I just kept fucking walking around.
He just looked like a big spoiled brat and I seen all 10 attains.
I like to,
okay,
but this guy,
you know,
he's like a fucking Mama's boy.
You just tell he just got everything you wanted in life.
You know,
he wanted another meatball and they fucking gave it to him.
And that's why he's a sad bastard and that's why he has to stand up during the
flight and fucking lean,
lean on the chair.
At one point,
he literally,
he was on diagonally behind me and he's fucking lean and over our fucking row.
Like,
he just ran a marathon or he's fucking ran suicides trying to make a hoop team.
Right.
So it was fucking hand is in my sight and I literally fucking fucking elbow his
hand.
I just,
you know,
I don't know if that broke some sort of nine 11 are you a terrorist fucking
code?
But it's just,
Ooh,
I always wanted to go to Italy.
I know I still do,
but right now I don't.
I really don't.
Speaking of great food,
Italian food could never,
ever,
ever be overrated.
Best fucking food out there.
And then wines and say,
do you have any that Barolo,
is that what it's called?
That red wine is fucking insane.
70 75 bucks,
you know,
go out and get a bottle,
and just have a glass.
Don't be a Douche.
Don't fucking start swinging it like a pirate.
Okay.
It's a fucking great one.
All right,
moving on here.
Uh
Oh.
Here's a white wine.
White wine is overrated and this is his.
This is reason.
White wine.
And then in parentheses it just says,
shit sucks.
I like to,
if that's not alliteration,
is it?
It's just,
I dunno.
White wine,
white wine shit sucks.
Two syllables,
two syllables.
That's like a full house of fucking grammar or two pair.
Anyways.
All right.
Cats.
Cats are overrated.
They have no right to be classed anywhere near a dog home theater surround
sound.
It's cool for about two months and then it's a pain in the ass.
I tell you something,
I don't,
I forget who wrote this shit,
but you know what?
This person is onto some stuff.
Surround sound does suck.
Thank you.
Remember when you got it right and you had to fucking figure out how to run the
wires down along the wall and then behind your couch without any company seeing
it.
Then you had that.
Then a year later they came up with the wireless shit.
Then you got to somehow drill a hole in your fucking wall and then,
you know what I mean?
Then it's like just,
it's just too fucking loud.
You got literally imax sound in a fucking 30 square foot room.
At least I did one bedroom apartment.
Oh,
hey,
here's one.
This one might set off some people he had.
Somebody said,
Oliver Stone is overrated guy makes horrible movies,
natural born killers,
Scarface.
Any given Sunday,
only good one he ever made was people versus Larry Flint.
All right.
You might get some,
uh,
some people arguing on that one did,
did he,
I thought Brian de Palma did Scarface.
That Oliver stone right in or something.
I wasn't a fan of natural born killers.
I didn't like how it reminded me of Madonna.
Like you're like,
oh my God,
Madonna's so fucking cheesy.
She's thinks,
and then she's,
then she has the out of like,
no,
it's supposed to be cheesy.
A mocking pop music,
you know,
that type of shit.
I thought natural born killers was like the,
it's like,
I got it.
Within the first five minutes I got it,
I was over it.
And then the whole defense of the movie,
it's like,
that's the point,
man.
The violence,
you don't even have a reaction to it.
It's like you're immune to it.
No,
dude,
that movie sucked.
There was some great performances,
but all those fucking edits,
it was fucking ridiculous.
It was like,
it's like one of those SNL movies where they just,
it's a sketch and I stretch it out into a movie.
That's what I felt natural born killers with.
Like,
you know,
it was like,
I got it,
I got it.
And you're still doing it.
It was one note.
All right,
last couple and then we're going to wrap this up.
Kanye west,
he said I like two songs,
but he seems way too cocky and over played on the radio and TV kind of seems
like you just don't like Kanye.
Tupac.
Just because he's dead doesn't mean that he was great.
He had about five good songs out of 10 million.
You know what?
I'm going to have to agree with the,
I never,
you know,
worries about Tupac.
He fucking,
he never switched up the way he phrased his shit or his flow or whatever the
fuck you supposed to say.
Every song was the same cadence that nobody did and I think I'm going to die
everything.
Well,
rose is the concrete.
We'll just single model
and I think I'm going to,
it's fucking terrible.
You know what it was about that guy,
he had like those fucking,
he had those uh,
adopted dog,
big Brown fucking eyeballs,
you know,
and Sarah mcglothlin sings that song.
[inaudible] oh
yeah,
he had that fucking face.
So everybody liked him and then he wrote a bunch of shit on his stomach and then
he had his,
he had his cadence and he fucking,
he was,
he was more of a hypnotist.
I like biggie way better.
There we go.
That artist start a fucking debate.
Who Do you like better?
Huh?
You know what?
Why don't you guys send me something and what,
you know the band that's getting all the attention and the person you think
should be,
you know what I mean?
And don't say Nickelback is everybody picks on them.
We all know they're a,
I don't know if they suck.
They're just annoying.
Um,
all right,
the last few here,
a overrated I iPhones,
organic produce,
blondes,
breasts and religion.
Organic produce.
I like that one cause I buy that shit and it's fucking expensive and I don't
feel a whole lot better.
Um,
I think that might be it.
Oh,
one guy had a heat.
One guy had was fucking annoyed about the tattoo comment that I made last week
about those,
you know,
those sleeves people get,
I like seeing like one cool tattoo surrounded by a bunch of skin so I can see
what the fuck it is.
You know what I mean?
As opposed to,
uh,
you know,
it just looks like somebody scribbled all over somebody fucking arm and then
what happens is you fucking looking at the guys aren't trying to figure out what
it is.
Then he starts thinking,
you're looking at him and then you were in a fucking situation.
You know,
it's like,
do well maybe if you didn't have fucking rhyme of the ancient mariner on you got
damn elbow.
I wouldn't have to look at you so fucking long.
But anyways,
this is what this guy says.
He says,
okay,
I have to chime in about the tattoo sleeve topics on this week's podcast.
I agree that there are a lot of paper gangsters.
I guess phony people are out there getting ink done lately,
but usually it's something queer like a Barb wire armband or some tribal ass
shit or some gay ass cartoon.
It's fucking dumb.
All right.
Just to stop this paragraph for a second and do a little history of tattoos that
I've noticed.
The hacky tattoo to get in the 90s was the,
the barbed wire arm band.
Even Pamela Anderson has it or the fucking date rape is frat boy tribal fucking
one.
But the gay ass cartoon one,
that was more of a late seven.
That was like a seventies.
Uh,
what was that pot thing?
Everybody was into the seventies zippy or some shit.
What the fuck was that guy?
Somebody was here or is that World War Two?
I don't know.
But back then,
yeah,
like I worked in a warehouse with this guy in the fucking eighties and he had,
you sent me,
you sent to me,
Sam.
Yo sent to me.
I can't say that word.
How you say that?
Why did you send me,
I just want to say a fast,
you have a word,
you can't say it.
So you just started to say it fast.
That's what I do with it.
Your Saturday Sam.
Um,
on his fucking,
he hasn't basically on his leg just to the right of his ball bag.
And I know what you think it bill like what were your blowing the guy?
How the fuck did you see that?
Well,
here's my defense.
It was the eighties.
Okay.
And he was wearing Larry Bird level shorts,
fucking grape smugglers and someone was thinking about getting a tattoo when he
was at where he goes,
I got a tattoo and he fucking lifts as fuck him.
And he went back.
Then we're looking at it.
Okay,
what do you got?
Daffy duck on your ass cheek.
You fucking idiot.
All right,
let me finish reading this guy's complaint.
Okay.
That being said,
there was a lot of hardcore tat people out there with Nice looking sleeves and
not some shit just thrown together.
Okay.
Well,
you know what,
that's a decent point because there's a ton of people doing standup,
uh,
who just have jokes thrown together I guess.
Okay.
I get it.
All right.
But he said,
I was trying to get picks up my sleeve and my leg and but my space wouldn't let
me upload it.
But anyways,
I ain't,
oh,
everyone's getting tattooed.
But if you're someone who keeps count of your tests,
you're a fucking fag and should stick with a Henna attempt tattoo.
Hey Man,
I got four tattoos the size of a fucking quarter.
Fucking pussies is getting angry towards the end of this.
I think I've got to finish this.
The best is when they try to act tough and outs of pop.
Oh and show off the pint size tat and your face like they're all tough now
because they cried five minutes while
the guy did the work is one of the reasons why I don't read all these fucking
things is cause I'm not good at reading out loud and people aren't good at
putting together sentences.
Anyways,
that being said,
not all ink is overrated.
Just the facts.
Who get the my little pony on their ass.
Cheeks.
Dot,
dot,
dot.
Fuck.
Okay.
Little wordy,
but I get your point.
All right,
well there you go.
That's this week's podcast.
But the second fucking time,
uh,
thanks to everybody who,
um,
who's been adding these questions and stuff like that,
uh,
sending me questions and adding to the podcast and the underrated,
overrated,
all that type of stuff.
It's all going to go ahead please.
I let people know about my special on August 31st and please come back and check
out my page because hopefully in the next 24 hours,
my new,
uh,
my new video clip hype my special,
I kind of went out and just did some random shit to try and hype it and I put it
up on youtube,
but it's going to be up on my page and I'm going to have to do shit a couple of
those other videos just because it's taking too long to load my page.
Some people are telling me,
so I think I'm going to have to get rid of,
uh,
some of the old and bringing the new.
And with that I just hit power on my fucking Prius here.
You hear that?
He required that is,
I'm in drive right now.
I just turned on.
The light is at this exciting.
All right,
you guys have a good week and a,
I will talk to you next week.
[inaudible].